j'ouvre tout de suite le second débat de
ce sens public volontairement vous le
savez décalé de l'actualité du jour il
porte sur ce chiffre 28% au Danemark
l'immigration a diminué de 28% entre
2014 et 2019 c'est le résultat d'une
politique
ultra strict menée depuis 20 ans d'abord
par la droite et puis alors c'est plus
étonnant aujourd'hui par un gouvernement
de gauche social-démocrate ce modèle
danois et maintenant donner en exemple
par le parti LR la droite française pour
justifier ce tour de vis migratoire
qu'il propose au Gouvernement Flora
sauvage pour la droite française c'est
l'exemple à suivre le Danemark mène
depuis plus de 20 ans l'une des
politiques d'immigrations les plus
restrictives d'Europe dans ce pays de
moins de 6 millions d'habitants le
nombre de demandeurs d'asile a plongé à
865 en 2023 contre plus de 20 000 en
2015 et affiche un taux de retour
volontaire de 94% de quoi faire rêver la
droite française certains parlementaires
dont Muriel Jourdain ont fait
déplacement à Copenhague pour mieux
comprendre le modèle danois les Danois
accepte de parler assez clairement du
problème et dire pourquoi il se dotent
d'une stratégie migratoire qu'une
politique migratoire réussie c'est une
politique dans laquelle on modère et on
arrive à freiner le flux entrant car
autrement on peut ni accueillir
dignement ni traiter les dossiers ni non
plus d'ailleurs faire partir ceux qui
n'ont pas le droit de rester sur le
territoire puisqu'ils n'ont pas à qui le
droit du pays dans lequel il se rend le
Danemark fait tout pour décourager
l'arrivée de nouveaux migrants le
regroupement familial est devenu
quasiment impossible et il faut 19 ans
en moyenne pour obtenir la
naturalisation un modèle difficilement
transposable aux yeux de ce sénateur
centriste le Danemark n'a pas l'histoire
française le Danemark n'a pas la
géographie française et le Danemark n'a
pas la culture juridique française moi
je suis très surpris qu'on aille
chercher un modèle dans un pays de
quelques millions d'habitants au nord de
l'Europe et qu'on élude d'emblée la
question de la photographie notamment la
question de la politique familiale et
aussi les questions des besoins de
l'économie si un consensus politique
s'est formé sur l'immigration au
Danemark en France une majorité sur la
question semble difficile à dégager
cette question ce modèle danois est-il
transposable en France avec Marc
Ferracci bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
député renaissance des Français de
l'étranger membres de la commission des
affaires sociales à l'Assemblée Rachel
binaz bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste au service société du
magazine Marianne Renaul large bonsoir
associé à la Fondation Jean Jaurès on
est également en duplex en
visioconférence avec Anne-Françoise
hiver qui correspondante du monde dans
les pays nordiques et vous suivez cette
actualité danoise pour nos confrères du
monde bonsoir et bienvenue à vous et
Laetitia copain évidemment est resté à
mes côtés littoraliste politique est-ce
que vous fait rêver ce modèle danois
je pense qu'il faut faire attention à
l'idée de transposer tel quel des
modèles sur sur notre pays c'est
effectivement quelque chose qui attire
l'attention de beaucoup de dirigeants
européens à cause des dirigeants
d'ailleurs des leaders de partis
politiques qui voient peut-être dans le
modèle Dame Noir un exemple à suivre je
pense qu'on a tous besoin dans un monde
ouvert de penser une politique
d'immigration qui soit cohérente avec
nos valeurs avec notre culture avec
notre histoire et c'est en ça que je
pense que le modèle danois n'est pas
forcément transposable au modèle
français parce que notamment d'ouvert
c'est pas exactement la logique qui est
appliquée au Danemark on avait raison et
c'est précisément pour ça que je pense
qu'il faut avec l'exemple du Danemark te
dire compte du contexte tenir compte
d'une certaine homogénéité de ce pays
tenir compte du fait qu'il y a là-bas
une culture de compromis qui a pu amener
certains gouvernements à nouer justement
sur certains thémates sur certaines
thématiques comme l'immigration et bien
des compromis avec les parties les plus
je pense que surtout ces sujets là mais
on va en discuter le modèle gagne à être
observé gagner être analysé ne gagne pas
forcément être transposé bon je
j'entends vos arguments et on prendra
quelques-uns des exemples de ce qui
existe depuis plusieurs années au
Danemark Rachel Mina cette ce modèle je
mets des guillemets cette politique
migratoire stricte ou ultrastrer on l'a
compris elle mobilise en France la
droite le parti LR mais est-ce qu'elle
fait aussi réfléchir la gauche en France
elle bouscule la gauche elle la bouscule
parce qu'on aura l'occasion d'y revenir
mais le virage dans la politique
migratoire qui a pris le Danemark alors
qui est d'abord celui de la droite
danoise il y a une vingtaine d'années
tout à fait mais qui ensuite a été
repris et poursuivie par les
social-démocrates par la gauche la
gauche aujourd'hui a un consensus au
sein de la gauche danoise tout le monde
est plutôt d'accord et l'accepte
jusqu'au jusqu'à l'aile verte l'A écolo
de des mouvements des mouvements
politiques donc en effet en fait en
réalité elle bouscule bien plus la
gauche française que la gauche danoise
c'est à dire qu'elle vient poser la
question de la garantie d'un État
providence d'un état social fort avec
une régulation des flux migratoires et
une maîtrise de de ses frontières ce
sont des thématiques qui jusque là
étaient peu investi par la gauche et qui
a permis au social-démocrate au Danemark
de gagner et de faire aux dernières
élections le meilleur score contrôle des
frontières plan anti-ghetto expulsion de
réfugiés conditions durci pour obtenir
la nationalité je pourrais prolonger la
liste enfin ça pourrait être plutôt un
programme vu d'ici avec notre histoire
politique portée par l'extrême droite
là-bas je le rappelle la première
ministre elle est de gauche et sociale
démocrate avec des alliés libéraux si je
ne me trompe il y a une coalition qui
s'est formée Renaul large est-ce que
c'est l'électorat populaire qui explique
ce qui est en train de de passer au
Danemark et qui donc en résonance voilà
intéresse aussi les politiques français
absolument le principal parti pris du
Parti social-démocrate entre 2015 et
2019 c'est à dire l'opposition quand ils
sont dans l'opposition et qui perdent
les élections c'est dire on a perdu les
catégories populaires qui sont partis
dans l'équivalent du rassemblement
national qui s'appelle le Parti du
peuple danois et ils se disent comment
on peut faire pour restaurer en réalité
la force de la sociale démocratie
danoise qui passe par un État providence
qui est le cœur et l'ADN de la social
démocratie danoise et donc il part du
principe que pour être exigeant pour
aller être ambitieux en matière sociale
donc notamment une des une des mesures
phares du programme et celle de
l'instauration d'une pré-retraite à 61
ans absolument donc tu es dans notre
premier débat sur notre traite à 64 ans
donc on va plus donner au danois en
étant plus dur avec les je schématise
volontairement mais est-ce que c'est un
peu on plus donné au danois qui ont eu
des carrières pénibles donc c'est 38 000
personnes avec un système de prélèvement
de 400 millions qui permet de financer
ses pré-retraite à 61 ans sachant que le
départ à la retraite au Danemark ce qui
est pas le cas des ce qui est pas le
fait des sociaux-démocrates mais tu es à
67 ans le départ et donc il y a un
départ à 61 ans et pour faire cela la
première ministre estime que il faut
avoir une politique d'intégration il
faut de la cohésion sociale dans le pays
et pour avoir cette cohésion sociale
mais il faut intégrer il faut avoir un
contrôle des frontières et donc avoir
des flux de d'immigration plus plus
contrôlés effectivement donc ça c'est
vraiment le discours qu'on a tenu je me
tourne une première fois vers
Anne-François zivert
pour vous allez nous donner le retour de
la société là on l'a vu dans le sujet il
y a un consensus politique il y a plus
personne pour dire mais c'est trop
radical c'est trop strict cette
politique migratoire
alors il y a encore quelques parties à
la gauche de la gauche qui qui critique
peut-être pas tout mais certaines
mesures pendant la campagne électorale
la dernière campagne électorale
notamment il y a eu beaucoup de
discussions sur sur la naturalisation
donc qui prend effectivement 19 ans en
moyenne et notamment la situation de
jeunes qui sont né au Danemark puisqu'il
n'y a pas le droit du sol donc né de
parents étrangers et qui n'obtiennent
pas la nationalité danoise qui se
retrouve à 18 ans devoir faire des
démarches pour pour essayer d'obtenir un
permis de séjour permanent on parle d'un
permis de séjour avant de pouvoir faire
les démarches pour être pour être
naturaliser et certains se retrouvent
avec un permis de séjour temporaire
sachant qu'ils n'ont jamais vécu
ailleurs qu'au-danemark donc ça ça a été
un sujet qui est quand même été beaucoup
discuté certains partis critiquent aussi
la loi ghetto donc qui qui veut limiter
le nombre de personnes d'origine alors
nom danoise non
techniquement danoise comme on dit au
Danemark c'est-à-dire de
des immigrés de première et seconde
génération
ça c'est un point aussi sur de plusieurs
parties c'est pas plus de 30% objectif
d'ici à 2030 c'est ça si je me souviens
bien
203130% de mon occidentaux dans les dans
un même quartier quoi c'est ça oui ça ça
c'est l'objectif du gouvernement il y a
différentes catégories de quartiers
c'est extrêmement détaillé et précis il
est différents critères aussi donc les
ghettos ont plusieurs critères et donc
ceux-là c'est même c'est même 50% on est
en train de enfin on est en train de
baisser à 40 % le nombre de de
logement à loyer modéré donc on déplace
des gens d'un quartier à l'autre donc
c'est c'est tout un arsenal de mesure en
fait qui a été mis en place comme vous
disiez depuis 20 ans depuis 2001 par la
droite on y reviendra sur cet aspect là
concernant les les ghettos mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est que voilà vous
nous dites il y a quelques voix à la
gauche de la gauche de la gauche qui
continue de de s'exprimer mais sinon
quand on écoute tient par exemple celle
qui est aujourd'hui première ministre du
Danemark mettait Frédéric scène c'était
pendant la dernière campagne des
élections législatives c'est quasi un
nom sujet finalement la politique qui a
tout à écouter là
majorité des Danois soutiennent les lois
et la façon dont nous pensons à la
migration et aux demandeurs d'asile au
Danemark aujourd'hui
c'est toujours un sujet important pour
beaucoup de gens principalement parce
que dans certaines parties du Danemark
l'intégration ne fonctionne pas aussi
bien qu'elle le devrait et oui nous
devons assurer l'avenir
est-ce qu'il y a des personnalités de
gauche ici en France qui commence à
s'inspirer de d'un discours comme
celui-là d'un discours on va dire je
mets pas mal de guillemets mais plus
réalistes sur l'immigration alors
timidement si je lui dis s'il fallait en
citer deux ce serait Ruffin et Roussel
c'est peut-être les plus à même
justement d'investir cette question
parce que ils entretiennent ce lien avec
avec
le peuple les gimix ça nécessite mais
avec ceux sur qui le pouvoir s'exerce
les classes les plus prolétaires qui
sont alors même si on le sait la
préoccupation première demeure le
pouvoir d'achat le travail contre la
pauvreté les questions d'immigration
d'insécurité
la sécurité culturelle ne sont pas ne
sont pas absentes donc si certains
devaient l'incarner ça pourrait être ces
deux personnalités politiques à gauche
elle parti communiste je le rappelle
même si nos téléspectateurs sont férus
de politique on va prendre un exemple
concret pour obtenir la nationalité
danoise il faut avoir une résidence
permanente dans le pays résidez au
Danemark depuis 9 ans sans interruption
le pas d'absence supérieur à 14 jours de
semaine passée un test de langue il faut
bien passe parler le Danois et puis un
autre test qui a un test de citoyenneté
avec on a choisi deux questions il y en
a vraiment beaucoup des questions alors
évidemment nous qui ne sommes pas danois
je pense que très peu de autour de cette
table ou parmi les téléspectateurs vous
pouvez répondre mais deux des questions
quelle est la trame du ballet l'acide
dévoilée en 1836 voilà test de
citoyenneté ou alors une autre question
dans quelle constellation l'astronome
tir au bras a découvert une étoile au
XVIe siècle
voilà c'est il faut bosser quoi
pour pouvoir obtenir la nationalité
danoise aujourd'hui marque Ferracci
est-ce que ça on va vraiment essayer
d'être précis sur des points voilà
durcir les conditions pour obtenir la
nationalité danois finalement être
obligé de travailler presque de bachoter
pour et de très bien parler la langue
est-ce que ça vous semble
extrémiste trois radical ou finalement
justifier bon c'est vrai que les
questions que vous avez posées même
transposées chez nous bon courage
poserait poserait quelques difficultés à
beaucoup de gens je pense que déjà il
faut distinguer l'acquisition de la
nationalité de la possibilité d'avoir un
titre de séjour temporaire et de ce
point de vue il y a un modèle danois qui
est dur sur les deux aspects mais il y a
aussi un modèle qui inspire et qui en
France on le voit bien avec le projet de
loi sur l'immigration qu'on est en train
de préparer
et bien trouve un petit peu déco avec
cette idée de reprendre le contrôle sur
un certain nombre de sujets mais je
réponds quand même à votre question
est-ce que c'est radical moi je
considère que on a besoin un moment un
autre d'écrire un certain nombre de
valeurs et de communs communs au pluriel
pour s'intégrer dans une société c'est
une façon de montrer son attachement au
pays dans lequel on vit depuis plusieurs
années je suis moi-même député des
Français établis en Suisse et
Liechtenstein et ensuite il se trouve
qu'il y a un processus d'acquisition de
la nationalité qui est aussi assez assez
exigeant avec notamment des questions de
culture générale sur ce qui a été la
Suisse son histoire et ainsi de suite
moi ça ne me choque pas vraiment ça ne
me choque pas mais je pense que il faut
faire la part des choses et il faut
vraiment distinguer cette démarche on va
dire d'acquisition de la nationalité
d'une démarche un petit peu plus
temporaire et sur ce point je pense
qu'il faut aussi et vous l'évoquer à
l'instant
distinguer ce qui crée de la réticence
au sein notamment on le dit des classes
populaires vis-à-vis de l'immigration il
y a cette notion d'insécurité culturelle
dont on parle beaucoup c'est à dire le
sentiment que les gens qui viennent de
l'étranger ont des valeurs qui ne sont
très différentes et puis il y a une
autre appréciation qui est l'idée que
les immigrés ont un impact économique et
social délétère pour le pays d'accueil
moi je me bats en tant qu'economiste
depuis assez longtemps contre cette
deuxième idée l'idée que l'immigration
aurait un impact économique délétère que
les immigrés feraient baisser le salaire
des natifs que les immigrés prendraient
les emplois des natifs rien ne l'indique
rien ne l'indique est-ce que l'inverse
ne sont pas aussi radicales que vous
mais je si je peux me permettre il y a
eu beaucoup de littérature sur le sujet
et quand on regarde les spécificités de
chacun des pays notamment la manière
dont le marché du travail fonctionne
est-ce que les salaires sont rigides
est-ce qu'ils sont flexibles on se rend
compte que en France et en réalité ce
risque d'un effet délétère économique de
l'immigration est très faible pour des
raisons qui tiennent au fonctionnement
notre marché du travail si on raisonne
en comparaison internationale et vous ne
trouverez pas vraiment d'études sur
données françaises qui établissent des
effets délétères donc moi je veux
simplement essayer de poser la que
l'OCDE peut publier des études
puisqu'ils qui mettent des bémols à ce
constat bon
sur la langue
on décide de faire une petite
comparaison européenne
quel que soit le titre de séjour on
parle de nationalité mais ça peut être
des titres de séjour pluriannuels nous
faisons partie des plus mauvais élèves
c'est à dire nous faisons partie des
élèves les moins exigeants sur
l'accusation l'accusation de de la
langue française
c'est extrêmement important
mais le Conseil des économique il y a
déjà deux ans à produire un rapport sur
l'immigration qualifiée et il
établissait cet élément selon lequel il
y a pas vraiment d'études sur données
françaises mais juste sur ce point parce
que là je vous rejoins sur la langue je
pense que c'est pour le coup un facteur
sur lequel on peut s'accorder ok qui
facilite l'intégration et d'ailleurs je
rejoins à ce point cette idée là que le
projet de loi que nous préparons et qui
est aujourd'hui qui est qui a fait
l'objet d'un examen par la commission
des Lois du Sénat et après on voit des
conditions plus restrictives
d'acquisition des titres de séjour sur
le critère de la loi cette question on
pourrait presque dire de l'engagement
patriotique des immigrés pour leur pays
d'accueil pourquoi c'est important et
pourquoi tu as peut-être ça rejoint le
la première partie de notre débat ça
pourrait être un argument pour la gauche
en France d'après vous
je reviens une minute sur le casanoa
pour vous expliquer ce point là parce
que c'est intéressant les Danois
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait à nouveau
entre 2015 et 2019 ils sont dit on va
pas faire l'autruche le sujet existe il
y a une préoccupation de la population
sur ce sujet de l'immigration on va pas
faire l'évitement où l'esquive et donc
éviter de parler de ce sujet-là pour
parler que d'économie ou de social et on
va pas non plus faire le caméléon pour
devenir un copier-coller de l'extrême
droite on dit quel est notre histoire
quel est notre histoire politique
comment la social-démocratie a pu parler
du sujet de l'immigration dans le temps
et ils sont tombés sur les déclarations
des mères sociaux-démocrates autour de
Copenhague dans les années 80 qui
appellent le parti central à dire il
faut mieux qu'on intègre les populations
immigrées parce que ça devient on a un
patchwork de population ça devient très
communautaire nous en France on a une
culture à ce niveau là c'est la culture
d'une gauche qui a été assez
républicaine je vais vous prendre deux
exemples qui sont très emblématiques et
qui montrent que sans doute en France on
a des voix d'accès à la nationalité qui
sont différentes de celui Danemark mais
qui peuvent être intéressants le premier
c'est le cas du résistant Manoukian qui
en réalité mort en tant que étranger
c'est révélé être très engagé aux côtés
de la France et dit à ses bourreaux vous
avez hérité de votre nationalité moi je
les mérité c'est le premier point le
deuxième point le décret du 26 août 1792
où la nation française naturalise des
personnes qui résident sur le sol
étranger mais qui ont rendu un service à
la France nous sommes une nation
citoyenne en réalité c'est-à-dire que la
France c'est un engagement c'est un
engagement patriotique comme je vous
disais donc on a dans notre tradition la
capacité à renouer avec ça peut prendre
de une forme économique comme comme
l'explique monsieur député mais ça peut
prendre ses culturel aussi enfin quand
vous disiez qu'il y a dans les classes
populaires et pas seulement cette voilà
je sais pas quel terme employeur
réticence gêne parfois colère face
effectivement au sentiment que bah il y
a pas ce patriotisme ou cet amour de la
France c'est ressenti assez largement
donc vous vous dites que là il y a
quelque chose à creuser il y a sans
doute quelque chose à creuser et qui
correspond à la manière dont on a
construit la nationalité française dans
notre histoire ce serait pas ce serait
cohérent avec notre histoire absolument
d'être exigeant sur ce critère
absolument c'est ce que vous voulez
est-ce que ce sont les mêmes choses
alors c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose justement je vous parlais de
nations citoyenne le principe d'une
nation citoyenne ça relève d'un choix en
fait en réalité c'est un relève d'un
mouvement donc une identité par essence
est figé on l'a subi et donc c'est en
cela si vous voulez que la nation
citoyenne française la manière de
concevoir la nationalité en France est
intéressante je vous parlais du cas de
1792 où c'est des gens qui ont une
identité qui est très différente mais en
revanche à un moment donné ils se sont
dit le l'idéal français et celui qu'on
veut ses concerts et donc c'est pour
cette raison qu'on acquiere la
nationalité alors on l'a vu dans notre
reportage Éric cioti et théodanemark la
semaine dernière c'est pas le seul
politique français assis être rendu et
le porte-parole du gouvernement il y a
il y a quelques quelques semaines
et puis on va accueillir quand un calmer
tout de suite sur ce plateau c'est
évidemment une source d'inspiration pour
les députés et sénateurs et l'air
rebonsoir Quentin deux propositions de
loi déposées sur le sujet de
l'immigration voilà deux propositions de
loi sur deux plans différents la
première proposition de loi ordinaire
pour modifier la loi la seconde
constitutionnelle pour changer notre
texte suprême alors qu'est-ce qu'il y a
dans le premier texte au total 56
articles largement inspirés d'ailleurs
d'un rapport sénatorial sur l'asile et
l'immigration de 2022 on a retenu
quelques mesures regardez des quotas sur
toutes les catégories d'immigration des
battues chaque année par le Parlement
alors sauf en matière des îles le
resserrement de critères des critères du
regroupement familial la fin du droit du
sol pour les enfants de parents en
situation irrégulière on en parlait
d'ailleurs avec votre correspondante du
monde et enfin d'un exemple qu'on a
retenu le rétablissement du délit de
séjour irréguliers alors ça ce sont les
grands enjeux du premier texte déposés
par par les LR et il y a donc aussi une
proposition de loi pour modifier la
Constitution publique c'est là on a
obtenu les détails voilà le texte a été
déposé le 25 mai mais son contenu exact
n'avait pas encore été rendu public
effectivement nos journalistes se sont
procuré le texte son article 1 Thomas
vise à réaffirmer la préminence des
règles de la République et ainsi ajouter
à la constitution que nul ne peut se
prévaloir je cite de son origine ou de
sa religion pour se soustraire aux lois
de la République et s'exonérer du
respect des règles communes en fait
cette mesure vise à lutter contre le
communautarisme selon les LR et alors
qu'y a-t-il d'autre dans les 7 autres
articles de cette proposition de loi on
retient deux autres mesures fortes c'est
la première c'est permettre le recours
au référendum pour trancher les
questions liées à l'immigration
l'article 11 de la Constitution
délimitent les sujets sur lesquels on
peut interroger les Français ne permet
pas à cela actuellement écoutez Bruno
Retailleau le chef de fil des LR au
Sénat
moi je souhaite que dans l'article 11 on
puisse consulter les Français
c'est-à-dire qu'en clair un référendum
puisse avoir lieu sur le sujet de
l'immigration pour ça faut réviser la
Constitution mais je pense que où on est
dans une démocratie où on n'est plus je
pense que à l'origine du malaise
démocratique c'est que les gens pensent
trop souvent que leur bulletin de vote
vont pour rien du tout il faut les
remettre au cœur de notre démocratie
dernière mesure que nous avons retenu
elle vise à permettre à certaines lois
organiques en matière migratoire de
déroger aux droits européens tout cela
fait dire à la gauche que LR penche vers
le rassemblement national écouter ce
matin et Yannick Jadot c'était sur notre
antenne
a totalement dérivé vers l'extrême
droite il y a qu'à les écouter sur
l'immigration franchement c'est devenu
totalement lunaire ah oui quand vous en
êtes quasiment à
hésiter sur le droit du sol le droit du
sang quand vous faites des immigrés les
boucs émissaires de toutes les
difficultés de la France quand vous
focalisez là-dessus quand vous êtes dans
aussi dans une dérive libérale vous
contestez tous les contre-pouvoirs de la
République et des institutions c'est
totalement fou c'est Orban c'est le pis
en Pologne voilà c'est proposition de
loi déplaise également à la majorité
présidentielle vous avez pris pour nous
le dire aussi sur ce plateau mais on a
entendu le président de la commission
des lois de l'Assemblée nationale Sacha
Oullier critiqué ce effectivement cette
porosité idéologique entre LR et le RN
selon lui sur ses propositions de loi de
quoi aussi Thomas compliquer la
recherche d'un consensus pour le
Gouvernement sur ce projet de loi
immigration qui doit être présenté en
juillet merci beaucoup Quentin Marc
ferrati je voudrais qu'on s'intéresse
d'abord à la question de de du
référendum
est-ce que il faut changer la
constitution est-ce que un référendum
sur l'immigration il faut donner la
possibilité aux Français de voter
là-dessus par référendum on voit bien
qu'il y ait des arrière-pensées cette
proposition il y a l'idée de faire ce
prononcer les Français sur des textes
qui ont et on le voit bien quand on les
discute article après article une
dimension très complexe en général quand
on fait un référendum on vote sur un
projet de loi c'est le principe le
projet de loi qui nous est aujourd'hui
proposé de discuter au Parlement c'est
un projet de loi dont moi-même en tant
que parlementaire je mets du temps je
vais encore mettre du temps à saisir
toute la complexité toutes les
subtilités donc l'arrière-pensée ici
c'est au fond de simplifier à travers
une question qui serait posée de manière
unidimensionnelle oui ou non à un projet
de loi soumis au référendum des
questions qui sont éminemment complexes
et moi je pense qu'il faut faire
attention pas la capacité à lire le
contenu à son imprégner avant de décider
où on peut je fais vraiment acte
d'humilité en disant ça même les
parlementaires sont en difficulté face à
des sujets dans des projets de loi qui
ne maîtrisent pas toujours sur le bout
des doigts et donc s'il y a une
démocratie parlementaire c'est aussi
pour éviter cela ça c'est le premier
point mais moi j'ai pas de problème de
principe parce qu'on discute du contenu
et du périmètre de l'article 11 de la
Constitution c'est-à-dire des thèmes qui
peuvent être soumis à référendum mais je
veux dire que en l'espèce il me semble
qu'il y a une démarche qui est un petit
peu cousue de fil blanc
et à l'Assemblée renaul large on peut
imaginer ce que serait une campagne
électorale sur un homme comme celui-là
dans le climat français avec les risques
surenchères qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
écoutez je ne sais pas en réalité
comment tournerait une campagne de cette
de cette nature là en revanche ce que je
vois
dans le cas dans le cas danois et ce qui
est assez ce qui est assez emblématique
c'est que la prise en compte de ce sujet
là par la majorité qui en l'espèce était
sociale démocrate a fait évoluer
substantiellement le rôle de l'extrême
droite dans le pays on a une extrême
droite qui est passé de 20% en 2019 à 9%
on aurait été aux dernières élections
donc il y a une chute assez drastique
quand le sujet a été prise en compte
donc est-ce que c'est le référendum
est-ce que c'est autre chose je ne sais
pas mais en revanche le sujet prison
envisager le résultat du référendum
est-ce que vous pourriez envisager si le
référendum avait ce que ça donnerait
voilà qu'est-ce que ça donne est-ce que
c'est pas ça la plus grande crainte des
politiques donc on n'a jamais peur du
résultat d'un référendum mais encore une
fois moi je pense que l'argument que
j'évoquais je veux pas y revenir mais
c'est un argument de bon sens il y a une
démocratie parlementaire au fond pour
gérer cette cette complexité alors
surtout les sujets je reviens vers
Anne-François hiver parce que
effectivement c'est intéressant le le
poids de l'extrême droite aujourd'hui au
Danemark est-ce que effectivement le à
partir du moment où tous les autres
partis finalement on digéré et appliquer
une mesure où une politique migratoire
stricte ça c'est ça qui a vidé l'extrême
droite de son poids politique de son
poids électoral
alors il faut faire très attention parce
que on avait un parti d'extrême droite
le Parti du peuple danois effectivement
pendant des années qui a été jusqu'à 20%
dans les élections législatives on en a
trois désormais qui ensemble ont fait 14
% aux dernières élections et qui
pourraient tout à fait augmenter puisque
le Parti du peuple danois pour
différentes raisons n'est quasiment plus
existants il a obtenu 2% des voix en
2022 par contre la plupart des députés
ces idées sont programmes ont été
complètement siphonnés par un nouveau
parti qui venait juste être créé donc il
n'a pas eu le temps de mener une
campagne solide qui pourrait tout à fait
gagner beaucoup plus aux prochaines
élections et à côté de ça il faut se
rappeler que d'accord peut-être oui le
[Musique]
l'extrême droite pèse moins que que le
pète n'est plus à 20% par contre c'est
pas juste son programme qui appliqué
c'est sa rhétorique aussi qu'on retrouve
dans tous les partis la façon dont on
parle des étrangers au Danemark pourrait
je pense sur prendre pas mal de gens en
France notamment quand ça vient
du Parti social-démocrate et vous
parliez tout à l'heure de des règles
pour la naturalisation alors elles sont
strictes mais elles sont dursies tous
les ans quasiment tous les ans par un
nouveau gouvernement c'est la routine
donc il y en a d'autres des règles il y
a aussi le fait qu'on ne peut pas
obtenir la nationalité si on a été
condamné à la prison que ce soit une
prison ferme ou la prison avec sursis
par exemple il y a la poignée de mains
obligatoires qui est vraiment un signal
envoyé aux musulmans qui a été mis en
place il y a quelques années donc une
fois qu'on a obtenu la naturalisation on
est toujours pas naturalisé si on ne
tire pas la main de l'élu dans sa
commune pendant le covid on ne pouvait
pas on ne pouvait pas saluer on a une
question
nous interrompre mais petite question
est-ce que finalement le fait que à la
fois les idées et les mots ce que vous
venez de l'extrême droite et diffusé
percolé dans l'ensemble de la classe
politique est-ce que ça libère aussi une
parole et des actes racistes au Danemark
ça c'est évident des actes pas
c'est difficilement mesurable il y a pas
une montée d'actes racistes ces
dernières années par contre il y a
effectivement des propos qui sont tenus
assez régulièrement et que les étrangers
alors des Danois même d'origine immigrée
dénonce très régulièrement il y a eu
différents scandales assez récemment il
y a aussi le fait que toutes ces mesures
elles sont mises en place au nom de
l'intégration les étrangers et les
Danois d'origine étrangère ont beaucoup
de mal à se sentir danois ils sont en
permanence ramenés à leur origine et on
parle pas juste des immigrés de première
génération par le immigrés de deuxième
de troisième génération puisqu'on fait
des statistiques sur les 3e générations
des jeunes qui qui sont qui pensaient
danois qui est 18 ans découvrent qui
sont finalement pas danois ils ont pas
les mêmes droits que leurs copains on a
aussi des Danois qui sont surpris de
revenir au Danemark avec un conjoint
étranger non européen et qui découvre
qui sont soumis au même règle que que
des qui réfugiés danois c'est-à-dire
qu'il n'arrive pas à obtenir le droit
pour leur conjoint de rester au Danemark
ou en tout cas
les conditions qui sont à poser sont
extrêmement drastiques qui fait qu'il y
a énormément de gens qui repartent ou
bien qui vont même s'installer dans les
pays voisins la Suède ou l'Allemagne ou
c'est plus facile de s'installer avec
son son conjoint étranger pour un Danois
alors ce thème il est vraiment le thème
de notre débat passionnant parce qu'on
voit c'est résonnant aussi avec la
société française et la vie politique
française Laetitia on va se concentrer
grâce à vous pendant quelques minutes
sur une voie qu'on attendait pas
forcément sur ce sujet que c'est exprimé
ces derniers jours dans la presse celle
de l'ancien Premier ministre Edouard
Philippe dans l'Express avec des mots
qui tranchent avec le discours qu'on
connaissait de lui auparavant oui un
discours plutôt correct on va dire un
peu contrôler et ben alors là il doit
Philippe on va dire ne prend pas du tout
ce sujet avec des pincettes et c'est
pour cette raison que L'Express
certainement a choisi de le mettre en
une avec ces mots accrocheurs les maux
d'Edouard Philippe l'immigration subit à
l'Algérie délinquance on crève des
non-dits voilà ça ce sont les mots
d'Edouard Philippe dans cette interview
et c'est vrai que ça tranche par exemple
avec son discours sur l'immigration je
ne sais pas si vous vous souvenez en
2019 à l'Assemblée nationale j'ai relu
et j'ai revu tout son discours je peux
vous assurer qu'on en est très loin
aujourd'hui
le plus important dans cette interview
de L'Express alors je vais essayer
vraiment de prendre trois idées majeures
d'abord ces propos sur les flux
migratoires qui dit-il ne cesse
d'augmenter de façon exponentielle
depuis les 20 dernières années et qu'il
faut absolument contrôler les maux
d'Edouard Philippe ont un sens et bien
sûr une visée
publique c'est ça exactement pour des
problèmes comme l'embolie des services
publics il dit c'est très simple cette
augmentation rapide du nombre
d'étrangers en France participent à
l'embolie de beaucoup de nos services
publics je veux être factuel cela
signifie que dans un certain nombre
d'endroits évidemment pas sur la
totalité du territoire les services
publics ne peuvent pas fonctionner parce
qu'ils sont dépassés par la prise en
charge d'un grand nombre d'étrangers et
puis Édouard Philippe lève aussi un
tabou en tout cas agisse quelque chose
qui va à mon avis déboucher sur une
polémique qui va durer de nombreux jours
de nombreuses peut-être semaines il dit
qu'il faut carrément revoir l'alcool
avec l'Algérie qui est sur la
particularité de l'accord
franco-algérien je cite Edouard Philippe
cette partie là il dit il détermine
complètement le droit applicable à
l'entrée au séjour des ressortissants
algériens avec des stipulations qui sont
beaucoup plus favorables que le droit
commun c'est une particularité très
nette aucun ressortissant d'un autre
État ne bénéficie de telles avantages
ces factuels mais vous nous dites que ça
va provoquer pas mal de réactions
évidemment alors cet accord a été signé
le 27 décembre 1968 et vous savez bien
que quand on parle d'Algérie en France
cela crée une réaction presque
épidermique donc il sait très bien où il
met les pieds Édouard Philippe et il y
va aussi carrément Franco sans phare sur
l'islam il dit le communautarisme
islamique est une menace un risque perçu
comme tel par nos concitoyens qui nous
imposent une forme de combat politique
donc vous voyez Thomas ou Édouard
Philippe met les pieds c'est très simple
il se positionne entrée manuel Macron
entre le rassemblement national là où
normalement devrait être les
républicains sa famille d'origine là où
devrait être la droite et là on n'a
jamais réussi à s'installer la droite
pourquoi il prend la parole sur ce sujet
aujourd'hui alors
sur l'actualité immédiate il ne réagit
plus il choisit des longues interviews
comme celle de L'Express celle du point
aussi il y a quelques semaines et il
impose ces sujets de prédilection les
sujets qu'ils jugent primordiaux donc là
évidemment l'immigration je viens de
vous expliquer pourquoi sont
positionnement politique et bien sûr
intéressant pourquoi parce que quand il
parle par exemple des concitoyens du
sentiment des concitoyens Édouard
Philippe parle bien sûr aux Français
pourquoi parce que il est dans la
position du candidat déjà candidat du
candidat pour 2027 je pense qu'avec
cette interview il est candidat pour
je voudrais qu'on termine il nous reste
7-8 minutes pour faire un autre Focus
qui me semble intéressant ça rejoint ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure ma
préférée sur la question de
la main d'oeuvre du poids économique
positif ou pas des des immigrés dans
un volet de ce modèle danois je continue
de mettre des guillemets qui posent
question celui de la main d'œuvre 158
000 offres d'emplois restés sans réponse
au second semestre de cette de l'année
2000 21 je crois que c'est les bons
chiffres direction du marché du travail
du recrutement Anne-François zivert
rapidement est-ce que dans les voies un
peu discordantes il y a celle de des
entrepreneurs danois sur le le la
politique menée depuis plusieurs années
ah oui tout à fait et depuis longtemps
en fait parce que c'est ce manque de
main d'oeuvre qu'on découvre un peu
partout en Europe il est pas du tout
récent au Danemark ça ça fait des années
que les entreprises
protestent contre la politique et pas
seulement d'ailleurs contre les mesures
mais aussi les signaux que le Danemark
envoie parce que beaucoup de la
politique danoise c'est effectivement
les règles qui sont mises en place mais
c'est aussi une politique des symboles
c'est à dire qu'on on en rajoute pour
pouvoir envoyer le signal qu'on est
vraiment pas le Danemark n'est pas un
pays accueillant donc c'est un gros gros
problème on a beaucoup d'entreprises qui
qui cherchent des employés qui demande
donc il y a un salaire minimal qui a été
mis en place pour pouvoir faire venir
des salariés non européens donc les
entreprises de vente qui soient baissées
et pour le moment les les politiques ne
cèdent pas alors qui reconnaissent que
c'est un problème même en terme de en
termes de création de recherche de
création de richesse pardon pour le pays
est-ce que c'est renard je l'angle mort
de ce qui se passe au danois au Danemark
c'est sans doute le le point le point
oui absolument le l'angle mort de leur
politique en revanche je pense qu'il y a
un point qui est important au delà de de
l'aspect économique l'aspect économique
ne suffit pas en réalité à créer
justement ce que j'expliquais tout à
l'heure sur l'engagement la nation
citoyenne c'est un point important mais
c'est pas le point qui suffit en soi et
ce que les Danois ont fait à travers
leur politique nous ce qu'on voit à
travers les sondages si on sait suivre
une intention qui est une intention
populaire quand en France vous avez 55%
des Français et 53% qui en décembre 2022
vous disent c'est le sujet prioritaire
ce sujet de la prise en compte du sujet
de l'immigration c'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui ça
mais on fait le même sondage à la
fondation en au mois de au mois d'avril
2023 pour le coup et on se rend compte
que toutes les tranches de la population
et ce qui nous a le plus surprises c'est
les sympathisants de gauche ont une
politique appel en tout cas à plus de
fermeté sur ce sujet là dans des
proportions qui vont d'un sympathisants
de gauche sur deux je reviens à marque
classique sur la question de l'emploi
est-ce que finalement ça vous donne ça
met de l'eau à votre moulin quoi vous
vous voulez que le gouvernement de 7 pas
sur la question des titres de séjour
pour les métiers en tension alors que on
a bien compris qu'il y avait des
discussions avec le parti LR il nous dit
c'est une ligne rouge ce type de séjour
déjà expliqué ce qu'il y a souvent c'est
l'idée que les gens qui sont déjà là
travaillent qui sont intégrés qui pour
la plupart pèse leurs impôts puissent
initier eux-mêmes et avec l'accord de
l'employeur c'est important une démarche
de régularisation c'est à dire avoir un
titre de séjour c'est important parce
que aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup
d'employeurs qui sont dans une logique
faut le dire d'exploitation de cette
main d'oeuvre là et qui ne font pas la
démarche de régulariser leur travailleur
moi je pense que c'est du bon sens
j'étais pas plus tard que tout à l'heure
en train de discuter avec quelqu'un qui
qui est assez connu que qui s'appelle
Thierry Marx c'est qui est aujourd'hui
le président et bien du syndicat de
l'Hôtellerie Restauration
il est très favorable et leur position
très clairement exprimée à cet article 3
du PGL qui introduit ce titre de séjour
métier en tension moi je pense que il y
a une logique assez simple c'est que le
travail et l'intégration par le travail
bien c'est un socle c'est un socle à la
fois de notre efficacité économique
collective parce qu'il y a des métiers
qui ne trouveront pas de Main d'Or quoi
qu'il arrive et quand bien même on
formerait des gens on proposera des
formations aux gens et c'est aussi
quelque part un socle de nos valeurs
parce que donner la possibilité est bien
d'avoir un titre de séjour et parfois
d'aller dans une démarche de
naturalisation à des gens qui apportent
à la collectivité je pense que c'est
aussi quelque chose dont on doit être
fier donc voilà c'est bien votre avis
là-dessus et peut-être sur l'argument
porté par notamment le parti LR sur
attention à l'appel d'air il y a
plusieurs choses déjà la régularisation
des gens qui travaillent c'est la
circulaire Valls ça existe déjà depuis
un certain nombre d'années et c'est ce
qu'on fait tous les ans tous les ans des
milliers de personnes sont régularisées
parce qu'elles travaillent alors je vais
pas vous donner les critères exacts mais
depuis un certain nombre de temps sur un
certain nombre de mois ensuite que une
certaine frange patronat du monde de la
restauration ou autre appel une main
d'oeuvre qui en effet et peu qualifiée
plutôt que de ce de décider de se poser
et de se faire une réflexion sur les
conditions de travail et sur le fait que
justement pourquoi
les autres n'en veulent pas c'est aussi
leur convention collective en 2021 avec
16% d'augmentation donc on peut faire
on est parfois encore loin des minimas
et je pense que vous savez très bien
ensuite l'idée que les gens qu'on irait
chercher des gens enfin ça m'interpelle
un petit peu comme si les gens étaient
interchangeables ont échange de pays ils
arrivent ils peuvent travailler c'est
déjà c'est une espèce de déchirement
d'arrachement et puis se pose la
question alors d'une part de du niveau
de qualification nos immigrants on le
sait on a un niveau extrêmement faible
si on compare à l'ensemble des pays de
l'OCDE on n'a pas les immigrants que
peuvent avoir par exemple l'Allemagne
qui sont extrêmement qualifiés nous on a
une large part pour plein de raisons
l'Allemagne sélectionne énormément
et nous on a beaucoup d'immigrants qui
ne maîtrisent pas leur langue maternelle
ni à l'écriture ni en lecture ni en
écriture par exemple on a une
sur-reprétation et dernière chose on
parle du titre métier en tension on
pourrait parler exactement aussi du
titre de pour les métiers
issus de la santé
je sur ces pays qui se voient vider
justement de leur cerveau la Tunisie par
exemple le nombre de médecins que forme
la Tunisie tous les ans c'est le nombre
de médecins qui part se posera ensuite
la question du titre étranger malade ou
de la minute réponse là-dessus sur le
fait de finalement appauvrir encore un
peu plus les pays d'origine ça c'est une
préoccupation d'accord je la partage
mais ce à quoi il faut qu'on prête
attention vous parler de la circulaire
Valls c'est au sentiment d'arbitraire
les gens qui aujourd'hui veulent être
régularisés face à cette circulaire qui
n'est pas appliquée de la même manière
suivant l'endroit où vous êtes dans le
territoire suivant la politique du
préfet qui est en place on se sentiment
d'arbitraire je pense que dans notre
réflexion et vous parler de l'Allemagne
et je souscris aussi à cette idée que on
a besoin d'une immigration plus
qualifiée et d'ailleurs je travaille
avec ces 15 ans de mes collègues à des
amendements pour améliorer notre système
je pense que il faut à la fois qu'on
limite l'arbitraire c'est comme ça qu'on
sera plus attractif pour des gens plus
qualifiés c'est aussi comme ça et bien
qu'on aura une politique qui changera je
l'espère la position de l'opinion
publique sur l'immigration qui est
aujourd'hui négative et notamment parce
qu'on a une immigration relativement peu
qualifiée par rapport à celle des autres
pays merci à tous merci d'avoir
participé à ce débat à bientôt sur
Public Sénat voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission je vous dis à demain pour un
nouveau numéro de sciences publiques
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission
tous nos programmes sur la plateforme
Public Sénat point FR et puis notez que
demain dans la matinale Oriane Mancini
reçoit Olivier fort le premier
secrétaire du Parti socialiste pourra
peut-être lui poser la question du
modèle danois on verra bien belle soirée
à toutes et à tous